hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
facilitating transcriptomics of
sensitive target cells
with gentle cell sorting i am jennifer
woods of labroots and i will be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by miltoni biotek
to learn more visit filtonybiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain your
credits by clicking on the continuing
education credits window
i would like to now welcome our speakers
alina steinbach
the product manager for flow sorting at
miltoni biotech and alexander
johnson research associate department of
immunology genetics and pathology at
uppsala university
alina and alexander you may now begin
your presentation
thank you for your kind introduction and
welcome everyone to this webinar
today we want to discuss how to
facilitate transcriptomics of sensitive
target cells with gentle cell
sorting
the webinar is divided into two parts
in the beginning i will introduce gentle
cell sorting upstream of transcriptomics
and afterwards alexander will talk about
his exciting
research and how he acquired pancreatic
microvascular endothelial cells
for transcriptomics analysis using the
maxcon title
let's first discuss why cell sorting is
so important prior to
sequencing first we want to enrich our
specific
target cell populations and improve the
reads
second we want to exclude dead cells and
debris
in order to avoid cell-free dna and rna
contaminations
and decrease the costs
however cell sorting is coming with some
challenges
first if the cell sorting technique is
harsh
dead cells might end up in the sample
and this could increase the costs and
also
dna and rna contaminations in the sample
might result in background harshness of
the sorting can also lead to gene
expression artifacts
that lead to false results
another challenge are timely delays due
to slow sample processing
and these could lead to gene expression
alterations
again ending in false results of your
sequencing experiments
let's have a look at some exciting data
unsorted cells and sorted cells have
been compared
in regards to their background during
this experiment it was found out
that unsorted cells had
around 50 percent of reeds actually
being from a cell
the rest was due to high background rna
sorted cells on the other hand had about
97
of reeds coming from the cell and only
low
background rna showing how
important cell sorting prior to
sequencing is
on the upcoming slides i want to discuss
how you can improve your sample quality
with using microchip based gentle cell
sorting
the max quantile cell sorter is a real
benchtop cell soldier
due to its low weight and small
dimensions
it is equipped with 3 lasers 8
fluorescent channels
and 2 scatter channels this provides
full experimental flexibility
and the possibility of multi-parameter
cell sorting
if you are interested in more
information have a look on the website
the image brochure or the user manual
at the heart of the max quantity there
is a microchip
let's have a look on the cartridge the
cells are inserted
into the input chamber at the bottom
there is a mixing propeller
keeping the cells at suspension at all
times
cells are sorted into the positive
collection chamber
and the non-target cells will all flow
through to the negative collection
chamber
at the bottom of the cartridge there is
a microchip
on the right side we see this in more
detail
cells are coming from the input chamber
into the channels of the microchip
they are crossing the laser beams and if
the system recognizes
a target cells a pulse will open the
valve
and the cells will go to the positive
collection chamber
all the non-target cells will flow
through to the negative collection
chamber
let's have a look at this in real life
the valve is opening and closing
and here the green cells are sorted into
the positive
collection chamber
microchip based cell sorting is truly
gentle
cells do not get decompressed or charged
and only low pressure and mild shear
forces are present
another advantage is sorting in a closed
and sterile cartridge
is safe there is no carryover no
contaminations
and no aerosols are being produced
if you are interested in high speed
sorting we also offer our high speed
cartridge for fast sorting performance
let's have a look at how the cells are
arriving in a positive collection
chamber
for this an endoscope was inserted into
the
positive collection chamber the
cartridge was loaded
and the sorting was started
we can see here that the cells are
easily flying into the positive
collection chamber
another advantage is that cells are
strongly concentrated during the sorting
process
because the valve is only opening for
the short time that the cell needs to be
sorted
this can save you for example a
centrifugation step
sorting with the max current title is
aerosol free
here is a recent publication the
researchers used dragon green beads
and a cyclix d impactor assembling
cassette
to check for aerosols in the environment
the maxquan title was compared to a
conventional droplet sorter
while the droplet solder produced many
aerosols during the process
the maxquan title did not produce any
aerosols showing
that it is possible to sort biohazardous
material with the max current title
a genomics workflow using the maxwell
title
can look like the following first single
cell suspension has to be
performed for this one could use the
gentlemax system
or for example cells can be pre-inverted
using the automax pro
then cells are sorted on the max pen
title
and they are used for sequencing
afterwards
quee at the uci is working on
epithelial cells he is interested in the
diversity of the cells and therefore he
is performing single cell genomics
he is taking mammary glands from mice
doing single cell suspension and sorting
the cells via flow
sorting and afterwards he performs 10x
genomics
interestingly he does a head-to-head
comparison
of the facts droplet sorter and the max
quantity
first he observes that the cell types
and states between the cells sorted on
the title and the facts droplet sorter
are similar however when he takes a
closer look
at the data he sees that the cells
from the max quantity gave more
gene reads indicating a better sample
quality
he is also looking at the stress
response gene expression
and he sees that the cells sorted from
the maximum tidal
had a lower expression of stress
response genes
finally he also performs a functional
assay
here he performs a sphere essay and he
observes that the cells sorted with the
microgrant title
form bigger and more spheres in culture
which is indicating a higher cell
functionality
all in all cell enrichment using the
maxscan title b4
sequencing improves the sample quality
and reads while minimizing sequencing
artifacts and costs
last year there has been a webinar on
exactly that topic
if you are interested have a look at it
nuclear sorting is getting more and more
important in genomics workflows
therefore we also tested if this is
possible on the
container a confidential marker was used
together with darpy to stain for the
nuclei
after sorting a purity of above 95
percent
was observed
i want to show you some recent
publications using the maxcon title
prior to sequencing
one example from covet 19 research is
coming from patrick wilson and his
colleagues
they are working on b-cell subsets
another example from covet-19 research
is coming from petra baja and her
colleagues and they are interested in
the t
cell memory
a study working on biomarker
identification
is using oligodendrocyte progenitor
cells
and there is an example from non-human
primate research
where they sorted retinal cells
to summarize microchip-based cell
sorting is gentle for the cells
sorting in a closed cartridge system
offers the operator
as well as the sample safety one
example for single cell sequencing
showed
that sorting with the title pre-edger
sequencing
can improve the sample quality and the
reads by minimizing
artifacts and costs sorting of nuclei
is also possible on the maxcon title
with this i want to thank you for your
attention
and i want to hand over to alexander
hello my name is alexander johnson and
i'm a phd student in the coarse grain
lab at the department of immunology
genetics and pathology
at solar university our research group
is interested in the pathogenesis of
diabetes
my studies are focused on understanding
the stromal cells of the human pancreas
i'd like to thank miltoni biotech and
labyrinth for
arranging this webinar and giving me the
opportunity to present my work
today i'm going to talk about our recent
application of the max quant style of
cell sorted to sort microvascular
endothelial cells from human pancreatic
samples
i'm going to start with a brief
introduction to pancreatic microanatomy
and highlight some advantages of using
the microphone tidal cell sorter
in our process after that i present the
project i was involved in
was recently published
first consider the human pancreas our
group is interested mainly in the
endocrine compartment of this organ due
to its role in diabetes
organ however the digestive enzyme
producing exocrine tissue actually
constitutes about 99
of the pancreas it consists of
parenchymal cells
illustrated here in jello which is
interspersed by a rich network of
capillaries
inherited by angles the
hormone-producing part
the islets of langerhans make up just
one percent of the organ and the
randomly distributed
wallets similar to the exocrine tissue
they essentially consist of parenchymal
cells
with a rich capillary network
the average eyelid consists of about
1500 cells
in the study i'm going to present later
we use the exocrine tissue compartment
sort of internal control to analyze the
eyelid tissue
now the first step in our experiments is
acquiring the tissue
for analysis this is done through a
process called pilot isolation
which is enzymatic breakdown of the
entire organ into clusters of eyelids
and in clusters of exocrine tissue
pancreatita are routinely received and
processed for use
in presentation or research at our
facility here at the department of
immunology
genetics and pathology if we are
interested in the transgressors of the
cells
we want to study the tissue as fast as
possible
which often means starting our cell
sorting at
odd hours
and well
this would make it very complicated to
coordinate our cell sorting with some
sort of core facility
um so i'm going to show you an example
of our
pancreatic microvascular endothelial
cell sorts
in this first figure we actually see an
unstained sample of eyelid cells
which highlights the quite high order
fluorescence
that is noticeable in our tissue
as you can see there is a linear
increase in version fluorescence
intensity for some of our cells
and we can see this in many different
channels in our samples
here's a demonstration of what our
samples look like prior to sorting
after we have the removed doublets
through gating
we have about 1.5 to 2 percent of our
cells being double positive for
endothelial cell markers cd31 and cd24
which must identify these cells as
microvascular endothelial cells
then after we sort the cells using tidal
cell sorter
we can reach a purity of about 90
percent
i think that the non-target cells that
we see here down in the
lower left quadrant are coincidental
events that were sorted together with
our target cells
it seems possible to reach a higher
purity when we sort our cell types so i
think this is some inherent property of
endothelial cells that we're trying to
sort
it causes this contamination
so next some things i quite like
about the microphone title cell sorter
and how we can use it in our workflow
um it is quite low maintenance and
easily operated instrument it does not
require specially trained
personnel and the core facility but
maintains it all the time
we could implement it quite easily into
our somewhat dramatic
workflow further the cells can be kept
at a consistently low temperature
throughout the entire sorting process
both before and during and after we've
sorted the cells
this is important in order to minimize
the metabolism in our cells
prior to test atomic analysis
additionally the negative sort of
fraction is retained and can be easily
used in downstream applications or be
sorted
is something we appreciate when we have
our quite
hard to get tissue material that they're
trying to study
and additionally there are the sorting
forces themselves
seem to be quite gentle for the cells a
very low fluidic pressure
no nozzle compression no electric charge
being applied to the cells
which would be in the case in a
conventional photometric cell sorting
this is quite nice since this problem is
the sorting process itself
has a minimal effect on the status of
our sorted cells
so now i'm going to move on to
talking about a recent product we use
title cell sorter to search
microvascular endothelial cells
my colleagues and i did this work
recently and have it published
in the journal scientific reports
so why would we be interested in sorting
endothelial cells
well microvascular endothelial cells are
actually a quite heterogeneous cell type
that line the inner surfaces of
capillaries
they are not simply a passive tubing but
they've been shown to differ between
vascular beds in different organs and
even within parts of the same vascular
bed within an organ
when it comes to the pancreas they also
constitute
an interface between the organ and the
rest of the body
which means they might be implicated in
physiology and disease the interactions
with nutrients
hormones and inflammatory cells they've
also been shown to be able to act in the
signal with the eyelid cells
and they are known to be lost in eyelid
culture and transplantation
however they are known to be
morphologically altered in both type 1
and type 2 diabetes
thus we decided to investigate the gene
level properties
of either microvascular individual cells
so for a brief overview of our
methodology
after organization we get our isolated
pancreatic tissue
isolates with various contents of
eyelids and mexican tissue
we separately processed our eyelid
samples with an islet content of
78 or higher and are exocrine samples
which had an islet content of zero to
four percent
in order to sort ourselves we first had
to break down
the larger islets and excel in the cell
clusters away from isolation into single
cell suspensions
this was done using the enzyme acutase
afterwards we stained our
cells using two markers in a fetal cell
both cd31 and cd34
and one marker for leukocyte cells cd45
we then sorted our cd31 and cd44
positive cells
using the type of cell sorter
having done this we took small aliquot
cells
for quality control analysis we
assessed the purity through qpcr and
fluxytometry on a separate instrument
and the majority of the cells were used
in rna-seq
and we then compared the data between
these two compartments
from our isolated pancreatic samples
and some results so in total we analyzed
eight organ donors with normal glycemia
and five with impaired glucose
metabolism
in order to be able to make additional
comparisons between
the healthy pancreas and the
more type 2 diabetic esc pancreatic
phenotype
impact glucose metabolism group was
quite heterogeneous
consisting of some donors who've been
isolated high hba1c
and some donors who also had treatment
for type 2 diabetes
so here are some donor characteristics
and to summarize this table the two
groups were highly similar for all
clinical parameters
such as stage bmi etc but they differed
statistically in the level of hpa1c
which is what we were going for when we
chose these groups
so we analyzed the purity of our sorted
samples
in our allocates we used qpcr to analyze
some genes that are typically expressed
in islets in excellent tissue
or in endothelial cells to summarize
this data we pulled
the data from all our samples based on
their
sample origin and
here we can see that the endocrine genes
glucagon insulin
are mainly detected in our
eyelid samples prior to sorting which is
seen here in black in the top row
but there's also some detection in our
sorted
eyelid and the endothelial cell the
samples
and i've seen the red part of these
circle graphs
it seems this bit more contamination
glucagon than with insulin
and for our exocrine gene amylase we can
see that
majority of the signal was detected in
our exocrine samples prior to sorting
with some level of contamination in our
exocrine
in the philosophical samples on a
comparable level to the eyelid
bulk samples and finally we see
in the bottom row that the endothelial
genes take on one which
is the same as cd31 and formula band
factor
are almost exclusively detected in our
sorted endothelial cell samples
next for some
post sorting flowchitogic analysis
uh here are two representative
osetometric analysis of our sorted
samples
showing that the purity of nuclear cells
are roughly
90 percent
to further evaluate the purity of our
certain samples we used
multi-subject cellularly convolution
music
a mathematical method for estimating the
cellular composition
of bulk or an ac examples by comparing
with both
transatomic data with single cell or
nasiq data
doing this we also found it that
the model predicted that we had roughly
90 percent of fuel cells in our samples
from both tissue compartments
and uh when we plotted this
data versus the facts data
we see that in general uh these two
measurements
correlate well with the exception of a
few
cases where the
music estimate was higher than the fx
estimates seen here to the top in the
top left of the figure
so we have reasonably pure samples
then these samples differ at the gene
expression level
and so how first did a principal
component analysis
to see if it was heterogeneity with you
know samples
and if you can see here the the samples
cluster somewhat based on the tissue of
origin
with our eyelet in the philosophical
samples
in one part of the pca and the ex-screen
samples in another
however there was no evidence separation
of donors with impaired lucus metabolism
or
normal glycemia
this heterogeneity consisted of about
700 genes that were upregulated in our
eyelid samples and 600
were upregulated in the exogenous
samples
in these figures we can see
counts per million that is measurement
of the
level of transcription on the x-axis in
the left
figure versus the log-fold change
on the y-axis and
uh additionally we can see how these
genes
distribute when we compare the log-fold
chains with the
log p-value in the right figure
so then we analyze these
genes through gene set enrichment
analysis and we found that there are
several gene sets we're upregulated in
eyelets
seen here as red dots and
another bunch that are regulated in
exogenous samples seen here in blue dots
in this enrichment map similar gene sets
are clustered together
in the yellow circles
which are then manually annotated based
on their function
i've highlighted some interesting and
highly similar clusters that
here in red there are regulated eyelets
and these sets are related to vascular
development and endothelial development
additionally you can see some various
chances regulated in the rest of the
figure in islets
including genesis related to modifying
the extracellular matrix
and regulation of various functions
i've also highlighted
the upregulated genes that's the
exocrine tissue
and these genesis were related by
molecular and liposomal processing
and next we started the top
up regulated gene sets
the go terms with our
with enrichment in eyelid samples
have a positive nest score as indicated
on the x-axis
again i highlighted some of these gene
sets in red
see that there's quite a lot of gene
sets that have to do with
escrow and individual development that
are upregulated here in our islet
samples
what could this data mean
from our transatomic data we can only
speculate on this of course based on the
earlier findings in literature there
have been previous
findings of increased replication in all
pancreatic cell types in a subset of
organ donors
it shows that turnover of the endocrine
tissue
is feasible at least under some
conditions
additionally there could be an extent of
physiological eyelid cell turnover
eyelid size is known to be quite
heterogeneous and the extent of
cellular turnover within eyelets and
whether smaller eyelets
grow into larger ones and the factors
determining the maximal size of
individual eyelets
have not been determined
so intra eyelet angular genesis
and external matrix modeling from
endothelial cells
could be an important is in this puzzle
it's enablers of
of cellular turnover and remodeling
so for some conclusions then
we use the tidal cell sorter it provided
a
very convenient alternative for sorting
primary microvascular endothelial cells
at
high purity
this allowed us to create sort of
atlas of genes that are likely expressed
in the pancreatic microvasculature
among these genes who found higher
levels of angiogenesis-related
transcripts in our eyelids
and the microvascular and the fetal cell
samples
this is a transcriptomic data that is
consistent with
ongoing tissue modeling that has been
previously suggested in the literature
and in our exocrine microvascular
samples we found
an upregulate the upregulation in
biomolecular metabolism so we don't
really know what
this stands for but it might be
some contamination from the exocrine
parenchymal
cells
and we also did not find any unifying
transcriptomic
microvascular endothelial signature that
differs between
subjects with normal glycemia and
subjects with paralysis metabolism
however we had quite few
subjects with glucose metabolism and
they were also quite heterogeneous with
some
not having a type 2 diabetes diagnosis
and some having type 2 diagnosis
treatment
so it's hard to tell what this
stands for there might be some more
specific signature at
more specific time points disease for
example
and that concludes my talk
thank you very much for listening and
i'll be happy to
answer any questions you might have
during the live question and answers
session
thank you alina and alexander for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
you mentioned it is possible to sort
biohazardous material
is it also possible to sort bacteria
with the title
thanks for its really interesting
questions of course
sorting off bacteria is a really
interesting topic
and actually yes this is possible there
have been
e coli sorted on the title and there has
been a bioburn test
also performed afterwards showing no
cross-contaminations
it is also possible to sort by mist
cells
also plasmodium parasites have been
sorted on the title and
yeah it was also possible to see the
movement of these cells afterwards
which confirmed on the viability of
these
cells and interestingly um because
due to the flexibility of the cartridge
it is also possible for example to sort
unaired
bacteria for example the buffer can be
overlaid
with an oil to keep out any
oxygen you can find on all these data
on our website if you are further
interested in this topic
thank you elena our next question is
what are the challenges of studying
isolated human pancreatic tissue
yeah so i think there are some
challenges both related to our signals
of suspensions and also to study the
design
so we have this high autofluorescence
that i showed
and that means that you need some quite
bright stainings to be able to
target cells in your parenchymal cells
and then again the eyelid isolation
process
single cell dissociation is a quite
significant
stressor for the cells so they are
probably quite susceptible to
additional damage during further
processing
before analysis and there's also quite
this
extracellular matrix composition in
between donors um which i think affects
the
number of cells we can get material
and how well dispersed those cells are
and then the donors
with diabetes we need we can't really
control our
diabetic time points very well in our
studies
thank you alexander our next question is
what kind of buffer do you recommend oh
excuse me what kind of buffer do you
recommend for nuclei sorting
yeah this is a really um complex
question i cannot give you a black and
white answer to this one
but what i can tell you is many
customers are using homebrew buffers
which they were already used to um yeah
employ for their um sequencing
experiments
um these buses are mostly based on pbs
um and sometimes also stabilizers are
used
for example sucrose or bsa
is also sometimes beneficial
but you have to be careful in case of a
homebrew buffer
i would recommend to check the quality
of your samples
uh especially if you have complicated
samples which are for example
debris rich um it is important always to
have an eye on the quality
and yeah as always in research it really
makes a lot of sense um
to determine the best buffer conditions
um because this is of course crucial for
the outcome
um and yeah based on your cell type and
your
sequencing application it
is an advantage to determine the best
buffer conditions
you should also of course check if there
are any substances that could
maybe interfere with the sequencing
application sometimes can be a problem
or also for example high concentrations
of edta might be a problem
and yeah so um this is what i can say to
this question
thanks thank you elena
our next question here is can you please
tell me the
procedure and time taken for the cell
sorting
yeah sure so the majority of the time it
takes is during the sample preparation
with single cell dissociation step and
stainings and the washing steps and such
take about two to two and a half hours
in our
project and then the sorting time itself
is quite fast maybe 10 to 15 minutes to
prepare a cartridge
and then depending on what purity you're
going for you don't want to load
too high concentration of cells but if
you're going for a high purity you can
sort about
a million cells in 15 minutes so i think
it's quite fast
resorting time thank you alexander
and our next question here is
approximately how long does it take
for the tissue digestion and preparation
step
yeah again this is the this is the step
that takes the most time
um so first we need to get
the eyelets themselves from the intact
organ donor pancreas
and that takes quite a long time maybe
four to five hours and it's not as a
separate facility
then after that we do the single cell
digestion
that takes about yeah by this in itself
takes about
30 minutes but you need to do the
washing steps as well on the stainings
and such
so two to two and a half hours a total
seven or eight hours i guess for the
tissue preparation i just
thank you so much alexander and our next
question
in context with sensitive cells have
neurons been sorted on the title
um yeah also a very interesting question
the neuroscience field is growing a lot
and we also have tested quite some
applications
in this context um
neurons and also neural cells they have
been sorted on the max quantity two days
um one example is for example neural
stem cells um they were sorted from mice
and it was also possible to
differentiate these cells
into pl cells and also neurons
um this showed yeah that functionality
of the thought itself
was good and yeah we also offer
a sorting and analysis kit for this
workflow
if you are interested you can have a
look on the webpage there is a poster on
which on this topic
um yeah in addition yes indeed it was
possible also to
sort um adult neurons from mice
um sorting neurons is of course very
tricky
on the cell side it's really sensitive
you may know these cells who have
long dendrites and um that what makes
them
so sensitive and also tricky
um yeah however it was possible to sort
this tell type
with a viability above 95
and if you are interested have a look on
this
on our webpage
thank you alina our next question
how many different cell populations can
be sorted simultaneously from a sample
so from one cartridge um you can sort
one cell type on but it is
then no problem because the advantage of
our system is that
absolutely no cells to get lost and
that's why you can simply regain
the cells from the negative chamber and
you can restore them again
for any cell type you might be also
looking at
thank you elena and our next question
here
what factors are central for high cell
sorting purity
yeah i think one of one of the central
factors is that you don't have
too high cell concentration um
due to the way that fluidic system works
and uh
that you apply a threshold close to
yourself when
determining the sorting procedure and so
that's highly important you don't want
to go above 1 million cells per
milliliter and it also seems that
there's some
some differences between different cell
types from my experience
but maybe some cells don't quite
behave like a well-behaved single cell
suspension
uh so endothelial cells for example seem
to be
able to reach a lower purity than some
immune cell subsets
within the pancreas
thank you alexander and we've got
another question in from the audience
what protocol do you use to dissociate
your tissue
enzymatic mechanical dissociation
we used enzymatic dissociation with a
commercial
enzyme accutase with some added
mechanical assistance with uh defecting
yeah great thank you so much and here
we've got another question
can primary dc's be sorted on the title
yeah primary dendritic cells are also
really sensitive
um cell type also due to their shape and
um indeed um there has been a recent
publication on this topic
there were researchers from italy and
they were sorting dendritic cells
interestingly from our healthy donors
and
also from covet 19 patients
for this publication downstream they
used
10x genomics and sequencing because they
wanted to
unravel the transcriptional response of
the dc subset
during the zak of two infection
thank you alina and our next question
what are the biological implications of
increased levels of vascular development
transcripts
yeah so i think it's our
readout is a bit limited in our in our
study
and what we can see is that these
transcripts are all represented in our
eyelid samples of course um so we can
just speculate on what
this increased numbers of transcripts
could mean by a lot
and there's some interesting work that's
been done in the pancreas that
shows there might be some increase it's
a turnover in the subject of organ
donors
and such a phenomenon could
mean that there will be an additional
lead for remodeling in the vasculature
as well
i think that's a quite interesting
mechanism that should be
investigated forever
thank you alexander what is the maximum
flow rate
yeah thanks for this question so we can
talk a bit
here about the technology
as you might have learned from the talk
we do have two
cartridges a standard cartridge where
you can run
four milliliters per hour and we do have
a high speed cartridge
which runs at eight milliliters per hour
um with a high-speed car which we take
advantage of the physical
feature initial inertial focusing
and it is possible to sort a maximum
of 50 million cells per milliliter
you can load 10 milliliters in one
cartridge
this means that you could load the
cartridge with a maximum of
500 million cells um
yeah this makes for the high speed
cartridge up to
110 000 events per second
um oh yeah i think um
can even go higher this is really no
problem
um yeah thanks for this question
well thank you so much for this answer
and we've got another question
is there a size limitation for the cells
that can be sorted
um question um
the size limitation is 20 micron
batch for cells in suspension so as you
know
cells that on culture they are
usually on bigger and flat but in
um yeah suspension you can
sort cells of 20 micrometers if you are
interested if your cell type is
compatible please you can also do a
feasibility
essay with our cartridge
thank you elena thank you so much uh
both
alina and alexander for your time today
do you have any final comments for our
audience before we go
so yeah maybe from my side um really
thanks a lot for joining
i hope you enjoyed it i'm really happy
that
we got the opportunity to present here
on
our technology and also the research
if you are interested in the maxcon
tidal technology
contact us directly at miltoni at any
time
you can also contact your local special
representative of course
and yeah i also want to say thank you to
alexander for presenting his research so
that was really interesting
and i enjoyed it yeah thanks for all
well thank you again and i'd like to
thank miltonia and ludwig's marines
webinar
i'm sorry alexander if you have anything
more to say i didn't mean to interrupt
oh sorry sorry yeah i would just like to
thank miltoni
and for renting this webinar and big
thank you to you guys for
listening and interesting questions
yeah thank you well and thank you again
both of you elena and alexander for your
time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor miltoni biotek for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye